coming up we're talking golden globes
fashion from the bold and colorful
that's another layer of just wow
the romantic and classic we've treated
this
entire experience as prom
and even the relaxed at home vibes the
stars proved
no red carpet no problem
hello everyone and welcome to et live's
the download
now the golden globes were mostly
virtual but that did not stop the stars
from pulling out all the stops when it
came to
fashion and i am joined by a few friends
now to break it all down and break down
all of our favorite style moments
including
content creator and beauty expert jackie
aina
celebrity stylist michaela erlinger and
e.t styles senior producer marissa
runyon are all here welcome ladies
hi hi you hi let's get right into it
starting with
you know the more classic i would say
romantic and glamorous
moments of the night uh one style
standout for us
was anya taylor joy who actually won her
first golden globe last night
she also i mean easily won best dress in
this dior
hot couture i mean but kayla let's start
with you her stylist was la
roche and you can tell from all the
behind the scenes footage he was posting
he was a huge fan of what they created
i mean and he should be she looked
spectacular
they are such a good team and this was
such a special look
not only was she nominated for the first
time
she really brought the fashion this is
your couture and it doesn't get
any more glamorous than this i mean and
not just one but two looks but in this
first look there was the whole sweeping
coat moment to
the accessories it was a jaw dropper
it was a jaw dropper and the jewelry was
beyond i think it was said that if she
wore over a million dollars worth of
tiffany jewelry
i mean that was really that was really
spectacular
jackie what was your first reaction when
you saw this
i was just like okay jaw dropping money
green
you can't go wrong and la roach like la
roche knows exactly what he's doing he
knows what time it is and i thought she
looked stunning old hollywood glam
and yeah i love the second look with the
cape
i thought it really really was like so
unexpected and i thought she looked
very beautiful very regal and beautiful
la really cannot go wrong and marissa
did you feel like you know this kind of
changed the game
in the sense where you don't even have
to show up to the golden globes in
person anymore and you could still turn
out
a standout fashion moment like this what
did you think
yeah absolutely that's what i think i
love the most about last night is
instead of seeing
the normal red carpet posing the red
carpet photos we got to see
the clients and their stylists having so
much fun together they look like they
literally had the best time i was
living for all the things that law was
posting on the socials
she looked incredibly glamorous and they
just looked like they had
fun in fact et's kevin frazier sat down
with anya taylor joy
right after her win to talk about just
how much fun she had
take a listen to this we've treated this
entire
experience says prom because i never
went to prom
so um we've had we've had a really good
time and the benefit
of not being in the room is that i got
to change outfits so i get two outfits
tonight which feels pretty cool
let's go from a prom moment to what i
would call a cinderella moment
andra day who also was so shocked to win
her first golden globe last night for
best actress in the drama she wore
chanel that took over 10 hundred hours
of work
to make this dress again she won and she
was only the second ever black actress
to win in that category and the first to
do so
in 35 years in fact before we get into
her fashion let's take a listen to what
andrea had to say
about her historic win and i'm the
second black woman
45 years they really gave me the space
to be said since the color purple since
whoopi goldberg in the color
purple only the second black woman you
know that's another layer of just
wow you know it's it's so exciting and
also heartbreaking at the same time
because we are
black women are so dynamic and we have
so many amazing
layered stories and so you know but i'm
just but i feel nothing but gratitude
jackie what did you make of this look
and how it really almost lent itself
to this historic and such a special
moment for her
first of all i'm rooting for everybody
black period i thought she looked
stunning when i saw this dress i didn't
think oh that looks like you know i but
i thought she looked
gorgeous in it i mean i love the fact
that she kept a natural hairstyle too
and kept it like off the neck and
shoulders to really kind of like
you know let the gown shine but also her
hair looked pretty i thought her
complexion looked
stunning and congratulations to andre
like you really stole the show with this
look
she looks amazing michaela i mean how
much
you you know what how much work goes
into creating a look for an award show
like this
do you feel like this was for them that
first
moment that almost like a debut for her
because i think we'll be seeing her all
awards season long but do you feel like
this dress was really meant to be that
first show stopper
coming out the gate with the golden
globes absolutely i mean
wearing chanel couture to the golden
globes is a statement
in and of itself um the dress looks
spectacular on her and in some ways i
almost felt like it was a little bit of
a nod to her character and billy holiday
with that slightly 40s dropped waist fit
i thought it was exquisite i thought she
looked like the star that she
is and major major congratulations to
her on her
historic win marissa i know you were a
huge fan of this chanel
i loved it and you know what i think my
favorite moment was how
genuinely surprised and honored she was
when she won like i got
teary-eyed she was so overjoyed i loved
that moment
she just she looked so beautiful i'm so
glad that even though she was at home
she didn't she didn't shy away from
going full-blown red carpet glamour that
was something i was
i was worried for the people who had was
you know were nominated for the first
time you know i
i was like please don't don't shy away
from it let's let's do it give me a full
fashion moment
this is your time this is your night i'm
so so glad she did it for us and for
herself
someone else who gave us a big fashion
moment on stage presenting at the globes
was tiffany haddish i loved the whole
vibe of this and also just the color
tones you know she
recently went blonde for the golden
globes just for this night
after her stylist la roche suggested it
to her and her
hairstylist after she shaved her head
over the summer and i felt like this was
so
a perfect golden globes look maybe it's
because it was the same kind of
hue marissa what did you make of the of
the ensemble
i loved this i'm telling you there was
no stylist busier yesterday than love
roach
he was playing it with all of his
clients i loved the suggestion i feel
like i well first of all i love when she
shaved her head i thought
it i mean she has such a beautiful face
and you a lot of people can't pull it
off and she looks so beautiful
so i'm glad she did that and the hair
color really made this look for me
because
it's this beautiful bronzy moment all
around
it's just she looked glowy and
statuesque and
beautiful i was so here for her in this
alberta ferretti
if you guys loved her in this daytime i
guess it's a nighttime look for the
golden globes
wait till you see what she wore for her
after party she changed into leggings
and sweats
for a backyard party with just seven
family members and friends but
it was so lit you guys that the cops
showed up to break up the noise
uh tiffany posted to her instagram a
selfie with the cops who swung by
captioning the selfie
the police came shut down the backyard
boogie down and it's only
seven of us hashtag we ready i mean
jackie is there anyone who's doing it
better than tiffany haddish right now
i mean in sweats and leggings she still
looks bomb
like her complexion is still glowing she
looks amazing she was actually one of my
favorite looks she looks so good and
again la roche like
look at the material what else do we
expect he's amazing absolutely
absolutely i want to get into some other
uh standout fashion moments i know we
each of you guys have
one of your favorites that you wanted to
highlight michaela let's start with you
who is your favorite i think i have a
feeling
i know who it is well oh gosh it was so
hard to choose but i had the honor of
working with susan uh kelechi watson
last night from this is us who was
presenting
and you know for me as a stylist just to
be back on the red carpet again and to
get
to go through this whole process it felt
so good and i thought she smashed it
this fringe george's hobaco couture
number
did all the work it moved beautifully
across
stage it flattered her so well and i
think she brought the confidence
that this look requires you know to be
pulled off
so really really happy with the way this
turned out
you guys really knocked it out of the
park and i got to tell you obviously you
got to see
this gown up close and personal but when
you see it on tv when you finally see
her presenting
do you get to like you know exhale and
pat yourself on the back and be like oh
it looks just as good as it did in
person
yes i mean oh my goodness the moment i
saw this dress
move i knew that it was going to have a
moment when it walked across stage
and that i think is the pinching moment
for every stylist is when you see your
work come to life
so it really was a great moment oh who
else did it for you what was another
favorite fashion moment of yours last
night
you know i loved amanda seyfried i
thought she looked so
beautiful in that custom oscar de la
renta
it was such an old hollywood vibe
with the sort of 40s wave and that
beautiful cowl
back draped um floral detail
and the color it was just it was so
vibrant and so beautiful on her i loved
everything about this look i gotta tell
you i love seeing art come to life and
she shared a few
behind-the-scenes photos of the gown
including a sketch of the dress and so
when you see that and then see her
wearing it i mean you can't help but
just
applaud yeah bravo all around
rob all around jackie what was the look
that when you woke up this morning
you're like still thinking about it
okay so just for the sheer detail that
went into regina king's look alone
wow impressive okay like over 1200
crystals
350 hours of labor that is a dress that
i feel i
that's first of all that's something i
would wear on on a tuesday okay it's
gorgeous
that's something that i've it's it's
stunning and i feel like you walk into a
room and you're like
wow and to me that makes a memorable
dress this for me was
that dress and it was louis vuitton once
again not something that i would expect
from like a louis vuitton but she looks
incredible she looks amazing she's
definitely one of those
artists and those actresses who knows
her body type and knows what works and
what
looks good and this was just i mean she
knocked it out of the park and you know
she was nominated for best director and
i think she's going to take this
nomination all the way to the oscars so
that i just can't wait to see how many
more fashion moments we get from regina
because she always nails it
uh marissa what was one of your favorite
looks of the night
it was hard to pick but i loved sarah
paulson
now i actually saw her first in the
telecast so we only saw her from
you know head and shoulders and just to
drape across her shoulders with her
shoulders exposed i thought she looked
so elegant i loved her jewels i loved
her hair and makeup
and then i saw this picture on her
instagram of the full look
she she was wearing custom prada and she
actually also recently broke her arm
so of course what does the stylist like
karla welch do she gets a
custom product cast to go over her cast
cover
so she was actually wearing this like
lavender-y
you know sequin paet product cast i even
love that they put a little logo mark on
that
i would keep that forever it's such a
fun memory from
you know something that's pretty
unpleasant like breaking your arm but
who
she makes breaking your arm look really
chic she looks stunning a plus plus i
loved this
an a plus to everyone who made zoom look
so chic i mean everyone really did
at a standout job while a pandemic era
golden glows made it look
very very different than what we're used
to i feel like because of we also got a
lot of bold
and daring and colorful style moments
and perhaps one of the most colorful
dresses that we saw
last night was cynthia arrivo in this
valentino couture
i mean what color would you guys even
describe this as but kayla can you help
us
i mean this is neon or lime i mean it's
so electric
i absolutely love this look her stylist
is jason bolden
and he really brought it home this is a
look that takes a lot of confidence to
wear and
she rocked it out and it takes a lot of
confidence and also it really does
it's all in the details as well as much
as your eyes go directly to this dress
you look at her hair her makeup her
jewelry down to her feet and even those
gloves i mean
did the accessories really put it
together for you jackie
those shoes i was like wait a minute
hold up how are you pulling those off
they were amazing she looked so
beautiful but at first i'm not gonna lie
i was hesitant
because i thought this looked better in
pictures than it did on the red carpet
and then i saw how i looked on the red
carpet again and i was like okay
i get it she looked stunning so it was
redeemed for you
it definitely was redeemed i didn't want
to judge you harshly too quickly but i
think she looked
really really beautiful i could have
lived without the gloves truthfully
though
but the dress overall was really
stunning on her
my first thought when i saw it was like
oh no she's going to become a meme i
thought people were going to green
screen things onto her dress but
i haven't seen too many too many uh
memes from that
valentino number quite yet
that we know of that we know of exactly
it's it's not
uh it's not too late uh let's talk about
another really bold
look from last night because i gotta say
the guys really turned it out as well
they had some fun of their own when it
came to styling for the golden globes
marissa
dan levy who also rocked valentino and
another similar color palette
a little more muted but i was so
obsessed with this valentino it was from
the spring and summer 2021 collection i
believe it's the first of the men's
collection too if i'm
mistaken i i loved this look
i i mean the the fact right now there's
so many designers that are designing
clothes that are pretty androgynous so
not necessarily labeled a men's
collection or women's collection they're
just clothes which i love
so that's what we're getting here from
him we're getting a full fashion look i
don't care who it's for
he's wearing it he's wearing the crap
out of it and i love it so much this
could very well be the color of 2021
after such a
terrible year in 2020 we need some
vibrant color like this to kind of bring
us back to life
i love that he paired it with these um
metallic
like oxford shoes i think that's another
big trend we saw last night as people
really having fun with their footwear
because they could be
more comfortable they were at home they
didn't have to torture themselves in
high heels so
and this you almost wouldn't think that
the two things would go together but
then
seeing it on him he wears it so well he
also wins the award for best
best lighting in background by the way
yeah his photo shoot at home was he
nailed it it's 100.
makayla what did you make of the
monochromatic moment
i loved it and i loved the whole runway
look you know down to
the creepers on his feet i thought he
looked great i thought it was
appropriate
and i thought he looked like himself
right and i feel like when he won the
golden globe for best comedy alongside
his dad who also turned out a good look
there's two of them together in their
color palettes it was like this kind of
spring moment
i go the levees are not only uh genius
comedians but also
genius i don't know fashion upcoming
icons don't you think i feel like
they're really turning out looks this
award season
definitely yeah i want to go into
another
bold look this one was a bold print i
would say uh viola davis she was styled
by elizabeth stewart
in this lobby by ck and i got to tell
you
this was so vibrant but also a little
bit of a surprise for me
i feel like we haven't seen viola turn
out a print quite like this or the
silhouette
um jackie what did you make of the
ensemble
well as a nigerian i'm biased she's
wearing what we consider
a traditional nigerian print which is
called ankara and
lobby by ck can literally do no wrong
i've worked with her
many times and viola looks absolutely
stunning these gowns like
they're so figure hugging and
form-fitting i think she looks
incredible i love that she went bold
with color
and once again i like that everybody is
keeping like hair off the shoulder so we
can like
see the dress and she looks amazing like
i love her she looks stunning
and marissa speaking of great backdrops
she chose the right one
for this look with the green behind her
i mean this is how you do it
absolutely i love that everyone had the
freedom to take the photos wherever they
wanted to take the photos and
show off their personality and she she
just looks so joyful this gown is so
joyful and so vibrant and you can see
that in her face and in the way that
she's smiling and posing in every single
one of these pictures
she had told her stylist elizabeth
stewart that it was very important to
her
to wear a designer that spoke to her
specifically as a black woman
so she chose up-and-coming designer los
angeles-based designer
um and i i love that choice and i love
that
i love when actresses take this stage
and this moment
to make a bigger statement with what
they're wearing and really express
themselves through what they're wearing
and that's what she did here and that's
just one reason why i love this look on
her
she's telling a story and sending a
message with her fashion i felt like it
was
more important than ever this year
especially after the hollywood foreign
press association
was under fire for its lack of diversity
and inclusion in their own organization
and so it was kind of amazing to see her
show up in this
she told women's wear daily or her
stylist did that she wanted to wear
something specifically that spoke to her
as a black woman and she said
in the age of diversity and inclusivity
we have to rethink glamour
and contour on the red carpet mckayla
looking ahead to the rest of this season
do you feel like we'll be seeing a lot
of
fashion moments that actually also
give a statement absolutely i think the
red carpet
is in so many ways an opportunity for
people to to share their platform or to
make a statement that matters to them
and i think this year more than ever we
will see that
um especially now since the red carpet
has kind of been reimagined uh since
we're all doing it virtually so
i look forward to seeing what people
have to say and how they share it
through their fashion choices
absolutely another look that kind of
went viral last night was jamie lee
curtis when she presented at the golden
globes
last night and the same dress that lisa
rinna and candy burris from the real
housewives
have each also been photographed in but
it only kind of made the moment
even that more iconic in my opinion but
i know that other
when i was watching the globes in the
office our jaws dropped when we saw
jamie lee curtis in this we were like
you better come through
with the chartreuse this yellow i mean
it just hugged her in all the right
places don't you think marissa
i do she looks stunning like these are
the kind of moments i live for she is so
inspirational and she's so bold all the
time and everything she does but in
wearing bright yellow i love that she's
been gray for a while now
and i think it's so beautiful and so
flattering on her um
jane fonda famously went gray as well
and i i just think it shows that it
doesn't matter
how old you are you can be glamorous at
any age
and she's clearly showing us this last
night
jackie i won't ask you who wore it best
but it's kind of amazing right to see
jamie in the same dress that we see
lisa rinna and candy burrison don't you
think
i mean a look is a look honey and i've
never been want to shy away from seeing
someone else wear a dress
because at the end of the day it's going
to look good on me
okay and i think it looks just as good
on miss jamie
or does she look stunning i feel like
you wear the dress the dress doesn't
wear you so it doesn't matter who else
wore it
you make it your own and she's
absolutely doing that and i love how
she's re like reclaiming
gray again like gray can be beautiful it
can be dressy it can be formal
it's not something we need as women we
need to like shy away from you know i
think she looks stunning and like she's
really embracing who she is
absolutely michaela i'm curious you know
obviously this is a really vibrant and
bold color is there do you feel as a
stylist a time and place to wear color
like that or
are we living in a time where you just
throw the rules right out the window
i think the rules have gone out the
window for quite some time and i think
this color was
amazing on jamie but what i love is
actually she chose to not do any
accessories
um you know there's no major jewelry
moment going on here and it really
allows
for the dress to speak for itself and
for her to really
stand tall and glamorous in that look
and make it her own
um i thought she nailed it you know
besides all these amazing
chic fashion moments at the golden
globes we also got a lot of amazing
relaxed at home looks people were comfy
cozy
while they were watching the show from
home in front of their zoom cameras
including jason sedakis
who rocked this tie-dye hoodie we had
jodie foster and her prada pjs and of
course bill murray and his hawaiian
t-shirt i gotta tell you i liked a ball
i was gonna say like as much as i love
a gown moment and the look dan levy put
together to see bill murray in that
shirt it just brought me so much joy
what did you guys make of it
at first i get to judge especially with
the guys
but people should come as they are you
know what like i can't even be mad
people should come as they are mr
siddiques is giving us tick-tock viral
star with the
tie-dye hoodie you know and you know
what like i can't be mad at somebody who
has
for decades perfected their craft and if
they want to show up in who they are
authentically
they've earned the right to do so and
these are absolutely stars who have
earned the right to do that
you know marissa what do we know about
that hoodie that he wore
well i know it's sold out because i
immediately googled
trying to find it because i'm like you
know what it said something on it it was
very obvious so
this hoodie immediately i don't know if
it was sold out before this or not
but it was a hundred and ten dollars um
says forward on it um and it's actually
he he actually talked about it um right
after he won his award so
let's take a listen to what what it
meant to him
it's my sister's uh you know dance and
workout place
in new york um but i believe in the uh
the product because it is a nice hoodie
uh as much as the uh
you know the message so there was a
special significance
behind it but i will also know i believe
he's in the uk so it was a really
late night early morning for him so i
don't blame him for rocking a little
hoodie
yeah no judge look great and also i mean
isn't that all of us right now
at home a little bit more casual i could
totally relate
i loved it i thought jodie froster
brought it in her prada pajamas
um but i was here for the hawaiian shirt
and tie-dye sweatshirt too
so um way to make it work
jody was a big fan of her pj's to her
silk pjs in fact take a listen to what
she had to say following her big win
the most comfortable and very beautiful
so i'm
super excited the whole this is the best
globes ever
to be able to be home but also it just
felt really real
it feels like a pajama party i don't
know what to tell you it feels like a
pajama party
not only do they get to be in pajamas
but they also get got to have their
family and also their pets involved
i mean overall do you guys feel like
there's a little probably perhaps the
most relatable golden globes you've seen
uh jackie i'll start with you i mean
nowadays
people yeah to answer the question yes
it is relatable but you know nowadays
people are wearing silk pajamas with
heels out and about so
it's an unintentional look in itself and
so i thought she looked
really really cute and you know they're
silk and they're not like she looks good
michaela any final thoughts on all the
fashion from the golden globes last
night
i'm just so excited to see that
fashion's back and that it hasn't gone
anywhere i thought it was such a
creative
um year this year and it was just i'm so
proud of my peers it was so wonderful to
see the way people
interpreted the golden globes red carpet
absolutely
well my thanks to our fashion friends
here jackie aina michaela erlinger and
of course
marissa runyon thank you guys so much
for talking golden globes fashion with
us
you guys can of course receive all these
looks and so much more over at et style
on our website etonline.com
stick with the stream guys et live we'll
be right back
you